الحروب استراتيجيه وخططها تحدث فوارق مهمه
على الارض وان كانت من السماء في اوكرانيا
الامور لا تخرج عن هذه المعادله روسيا من
الجو تراه على ارهاق اوكرانيا في الارض من
خلال الطائرات بدون طيار المفخخه رخيصه
الثمن التي تجلوبها من ايران والتي تقوم
بتجميعها من عده مصادر
تدمير الاهداف الاوكرانيه الى استنزافيا
فكلفه اسقاط مسيره واحده تبلغ اكثر بسبع
مرات من اطلاقها
رغم ان مهاره الاوكرانيين تزداد في تدمير
المسيررات الا ان خبراء عسكريين يقولون ان
ذلك قد يكون لمصلحه موسكو على المدى
الطويل فالطائرات بدون طيار ذاتيه التدمير
يمكن ان تكلف ما لا يقل عن 20,000 دولار
لانتاجها في حين ان تكلفه اطلاق صاروخ ارض
جو يمكن ان تتراوح من 140.000 دولار
لصاروخ اس 300 من الحقبه السوفياتيه الى
500,000 دولار لصاروخ هايمارس
وفق التقديرات اطلقت روسيا نحو 600 طائره
مسيره منذ بدايه سبتمبر الماضي وبالغه
الارقام تحتاج اوكرانيا اموالا طائله لصد
هذه الطائرات التي تكون اثارها التدميريه
تفادحه على اوكرانيا حاله وصولها الى
اهدافها
بلال الوجداني العربيه